we are told that triangle abc which is
right over here is reflected across line
l so it's reflected across the line l
right over here to get to triangle a
prime b prime c prime fair enough
so based on that they're going to ask us
some questions and i encourage you to
pause this video and see if you can
figure out the answers to these
questions on your own before i work
through them
so the first question they say is well
what's
a prime c prime this is really what's
the set what's the length of segment a
prime c prime so they want the length of
this right over here how do we figure
that out
well the key realization here is a
reflection is a rigid
transformation rigid
transformation which is a very fancy
word
but it's really just saying that it's a
transformation where the length the
length between corresponding points
don't change if we're talking about a
shape like a triangle the angle measures
won't change the perimeter won't change
and the area won't change so we're going
to use the fact that the length between
corresponding points won't change so the
length between a prime and c prime is
going to be the same as the length
between a and c
so a prime c prime is going to be equal
to ac which is equal to they tell us
right over there that's this
corresponding side of the triangle that
has a length of three so we answered the
first question and maybe that gave you a
good clue and so i encourage you to keep
pausing the video when you feel like you
can have a go at it
all right the next question is what is
the measure of angle b prime so that's
this angle right over here and we're
going to use the exact same property b
measure angle b prime corresponds to
angle b it underwent a rigid
transformation of a reflection this
would also be true if we had a
translation or if we had a rotation
and so right over here the measure of
angle b prime would be the same as the
measure of angle b
but what is that going to be equal to
well we can use the fact that if we call
that measure let's just call that x
x
plus 53 degrees we'll do it all in
degrees
plus 90 degrees
this right angle here well the sum of
the interior angles of a triangle add up
to 180 degrees
and so what do we have we could subtract
let's see 53 plus 90 is x
plus
143 degrees is equal to 180 degrees and
so subtract 143 degrees from both sides
you get x is equal to let's see 180 80
minus 40
would be 40. 80 minus 43 would be 37
degrees x is equal to 37 degrees so that
is 37 degrees if that's 37 degrees then
this is also going to be 37 degrees
next they ask us
what is the area of triangle abc
abc well it's going to have the same
area as a prime b prime c prime and so a
couple of ways we could think about it
we could try to find the area of a prime
b prime c prime based on the fact that
we already know that this length is 3
and this is a right triangle or we can
use the fact that
this length right over here 4
from a prime to b prime is going to be
the same thing as this length right over
here from a prime to b prime which is 4.
and so the area of this triangle
especially this is a right triangle is
quite straightforward it's the base
times the height times one-half
so this area is going to be 1 half times
the base
4 times the height 3 which is equal to
half of 12 which is equal to 6
square units
and then last but not least what's the
perimeter of triangle a prime b prime c
prime well here we just use the
pythagorean theorem to figure out the
length of this hypotenuse and so and we
knew we know that this is a length of
three based on the whole rigid
transformation and lengths are preserved
and so you might immediately recognize
that if you have a right triangle where
one side is three and one another side
is four that the hypotenuse is five
three four five triangles or you can
just use the pythagorean theorem you say
three squared plus
4 squared
4 squared is equal to let's just say the
hypotenuse the hypotenuse squared
well 3 squared plus 4 squared that's 9
plus 16.
25 is equal to the hypotenuse
squared and so the hypotenuse right over
here will be equal to 5. and so they're
not asking us the length of the
hypotenuse they want to know the
perimeter so it's going to be
4 plus 3 plus 5 which is equal to 12 the
perimeter of either of those triangles
because it's just one's the image of the
other under a rigid transformation
they're going to have the same perimeter
the same area the perimeter of either of
the triangles is 12 the area of either
the triangles is 6 and we're done